إلى رئيس التعليم في سي إن إن إسرائيل ،
مؤكداً أن رئيس الوزراء
نتنياهو التقى ولي العهد
السعودي محمد بن سلمان في المملكة العربية السعودية ، وزارة الخارجية السعودية ،
نافيًا
حدوث ذلك قريبًا لأن نيك روبرتسون
في الرياض أولاً أريد
توصيلك بهذه الأخبار العاجلة عن السيد.  نتنياهو
وولي العهد أورين ليبمان لديهما
المزيد عن ذلك من القدس.
لم يؤكد أو
ينفي أنه سافر على متن طائرة خاصة
إلى المملكة العربية السعودية والتقى ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان ، لقد قال إنه
يعمل دائمًا على توسيع ما أسماه
دائرة السلام ، لكن وزير التعليم
كان عضوًا في  حزبه الذي قال هذا
في وقت سابق من اليوم عندما بدأت التقارير
حول لقاء نتنياهو مع ولي
العهد محمد بن
سلمان في إذاعة الجيش
قال إنه إنجاز لا يُصدق ،
دعنا نقول إن مجرد
وجود الاجتماع ، حقيقة أنه تم طرحه علنًا
حتى لو كان نصف رسمي فقط في
الوقت الحالي ، يعد أمرًا ذا أهمية كبيرة
من أي جانب ومهما كان الأمر بالتأكيد
يبدو هناك مثل  وزير التعليم
جوهاف غالانت
كان لديه أخبار داخلية تفيد بأن الاجتماع
قد حدث بالفعل ولكن بالطبع هناك
نفي رسمي سعودي للاجتماع
نفسه ، إنه بالطبع ملاحظة كلمة جديرة
بالملاحظة
أنه في نفس الوقت الذي ورد فيه أن نتنياهو
كان في مدينة السعودية.  ناوم على
البحر الأحمر
وزير الخارجية مايك بومبيو كان
هناك أيضًا بومبيو على أرجوحة عبر أوروبا
والشرق الأوسط
على أرجوحة لمدة 10 أيام اختتمت بشكل أساسي
بهذا الاجتماع في المملكة العربية السعودية
حيث نعرف أن بومبيو التقى ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان.
بالطبع وما
حصلتم عليه لتأكيد وجود نتنياهو هناك أيضًا
عندما حدث هذا الاجتماع يوم الأحد اكتشف
مراقبو
الطائرة عملاً إسرائيليًا خاصًا.  طائرة نفاثة
تحلق مباشرة من إسرائيل إلى مدينة
نيوم وتبقى على الأرض هناك
لمدة خمس ساعات تقريبًا ثم تعود
ثم الأخبار التي أبلغ عنها باراك رايفيد
من والا وأكسيوس أنه في الواقع كان
نتنياهو ورئيس الموساد يوسي كوهين
في تلك الرحلة إلى  لقاء مع ولي العهد
محمد بن سلمان
، تجدر الإشارة إلى أن جوزي كوهين التي
تتولى منصب رئيس الموساد
هي أول من تقترب من نتنياهو ولكنها كانت أيضًا
تقود جهود التطبيع
مع دول الخليج الأخرى على
مدار الأشهر القليلة الماضية
بومبيو وترامب.  كانت الإدارة
تدفع هذه الجهود بالطبع ، كما
كان يُنظر دائمًا إلى المملكة العربية السعودية على أنها
الهدف الأكبر في تلك القائمة
لأنها مؤثرة جدًا
ولأن لديها القدرة على جذب
الدول الأخرى معها.